- So, Rod's career is so littered
with unbelievable stories
involving some of the most
famous people in the world,
so we couldn't have him here
without asking about a few.
So tough, you have to.
So it's time for Sir
Rod's Celebrity Stories.
(upbeat music)
♪ Sir Rod's celebrity story time ♪
- Hit it, Jessi.
I'll hit this button, this
really expensive button,
and our highly intelligent super computer
will sift through the
list of every celebrity
Rod has ever talked with, there's many.
Then one of their photos will be,
will pop up on the screen, rather.
And Rod will tell us the
story of that person.
Here we, are you ready?
- No!
(crowd laughing)
- Well, you have to be honest.
You've said you like to tell the truth.
- I do, yeah, let's go on.
- Okay, here we go.
Okay.
(bell ringing)
Oh, that's awesome, another sir.
So wait, so what can you
tell us about Sir Elton?
- We've been battling it
out since the seventies,
when we both lived, you know,
very close to each other in England.
But we love each other,
but we also detest each
other at the same time.
- Oh, this is like me and Blake Shelton.
This is our relationship, yes.
He's a country singer.
- So once, I had big banners
that I was playing a concert
in London, I had huge banners.
Blondes have more fun.
Was in the album.
(Kelly laughing)
- And Elton had it shot down,
he got somebody to shoot it down.
Shoot the thing down.
- Oh my gosh. Did he put anything else up?
- Mm.
- What did he put up?
- Brunettes have more money.
(Kelly laughing)
- Now that's funny.
- Absolutely true.
- That's funny, oh my god, okay.
So let's see who's next, here we go.
(bell ringing)
Okay, oh, Janice Joplin.
She a Texan.
That's where I'm from.
- Yeah, Janice, well, I was,
we were on tour with Janice,
with Jeff Beck and you
know, Ronnie Wood and I,
we're all in a hotel together
and she chased us around
trying to get into our trousers, I think.
- (laughs) You make it sound so fancy,
"trying to get into your trousers".
- Well, she was pretty scary.
- Well, I'm just saying most
Texans would have phrased it.
- We were tiny little, like children.
- Oh my gosh, that's amazing.
- She might have broken it.
- I know, but the (laughs).
Or you mighta had a good
time, let's go again.
(bell ringing)
- Oh, Freddie.
- Oh, Freddie Mercury, yes.
- Yeah, my.
- Wait, tell us about that.
- Just, just, it's lovely.
There was one time that
Queen were renting a house
in Beverly Hills and
me and Elton went round
to have cocktails and other things.
(people laughing)
- The truth, I love it.
- And after the cocktails
and things were taken,
we seriously were gonna form a band called
Nose, Teeth and Hair.
- How drunk were you?
- I'm the nose,
there's the teeth, and
Elton had no hair, so.
- Oh my god.
- Cruel but fair!
- That's amazing!
Okay, wait, next.
I just want to, that would
have been a fun party,
a fun hang, okay, here we go, next one.
Next famous friend is.
Oh, ASAP Rocky, how do
you know ASAP Rocky?
And please say you've
partied with ASAP Rocky.
- No, not really, he's,
he covered a song of mine
that I recorded in 1969.
So that's how we got to know each other.
But, you know, we haven't
partied together or anything,
I can't consider him.
- He's missing out.
- A close friend.
- Well, he's missing out.
Apparently.
- Yeah, he's, it was a good
song, he did very well.
My children were very proud
that he covered one of my songs.
- Isn't that something, you do
so many things in your career
and you feel really proud, I know,
and then your kids are like,
you know Ariana Grande?
And I'm like, you know what?
I'm like, I'm cool too, to some people.
Yeah, but thank you ASAP for the cover.
Keeping us real, it's cool.
(bell ringing)
- Oh, The Who, yeah.
Yeah, oh, wow, this is, oh no.
(people laughing)
- Wait, what was your.
- Disgusting.
- What was your experience,
oh my god, disgusting, what?
- Well, we, in those days we
used to take a lot of drugs,
this is a long time ago.
Can I talk freely?
- Yes.
- So Keith Moon would keep us going.
I know Bianca Jagger was with us.
We were in a crowd and
we stayed up all night.
Sun was comin' up and Keith Moon said,
we're going to a party,
it's still going on.
But we have to wait till the
public house opens at 11.
So we'd been up all night
and I was just so tired.
I said, Keith, I've gotta go
home, mate, I'm too tired.
He said, (beep) off, Stewart, (beep) off.
(people laughing)
- What's a public house,
what do you mean, a?
Like a bar?
Oh, oh, like a, oh, okay.
- In those days they used
to close at 10 at night
and open at 11 in the morning.
- Oh no, that's not my crowd.
- I was, I was the weak
one, I said, nah, mate,
I'm going home, I've
had enough, 24 hours up.
- Oh, I've always been the weak one,
there's like maybe two times in my career
I've done something fun after a show.
Other than that, it's
like Scrabble and books.
So that's it.
- You should come out
and tour with us lot.
- I mean, here's the thing,
I can't, I'm not like that.
I like having fun, but it's
never like while working.
'Cause it's keeping my
voice, I don't wanna suck
for people paying their hard earned money.
- You don't want to do what?
- I don't.
- I've had enough of this, I'm.
- Okay, okay, okay.
(Kelly laughing)
I teed myself up for
that one. I accept it.
But no.
No, I don't wanna be, I don't wanna be,
like, a bad vocalist on tour.
I want people, they paid their money.
- You're absolutely right.
- So, yeah, I always get
worried, so I was a nerd on tour.
- No, you can't, you can't do long nights.
I can't do long nights.
- Uh-uh, no.
- It just ruins your voice.
- Yeah, and I'm like, nope, nope, nope.
But that's enough about me.
Rod's new album is called
The Tears of Hercules.
Go buy it right now if you're cool.